cette carte une heure du coup il n'est
pas comme est seul avec son panier ses
bottes en caoutchouc
eva est venue accompagnée de sa maman et
ses cousines pour apprendre à
reconnaître les champignons regarde
comme s'efface regarde le pied aussi
aucune méprise possible le groupe d'une
vingtaine de personnes est encadré par
deux experts passionné de mycologie
membres de l'association des
naturalistes des yvelines qui propose
cette sortie avec l'office du tourisme
la première question en général c'est
savoir si c'est bon ou pas bon mais ce
qui est important avant avant cela bien
sûr c'est de reconnaître les champignons
puisque tous les tous ces champignons
aux ondes et sosie la famille va faire
attention car elle est venue avec un
objectif bien précis
c'est qu'il en connaissait pas c'est ça
on fait une à mettre avec elle va mener
13 signé avant - pour cela karina son
astuce elle prend en photo les
champignons pour s'assurer de bien les
reconnaître champignons rouler ça en
roule et on va demander au monsieur
enroulée mortels mon va m'être fait
originale parce que on a un peu
l'occasion de faire ça avec des experts
et est généralement on espère cueillir
qu'on sait pas trop si c'est si ces
taxis coupaye le met en champignon va
pouvoir se faire eva trouve le tout 1er
septembre bordeaux de la balade on
déterre bien le champignon bon bien le
déterminer par contre là on peut enlever
la terre pour éviter de mettre de la
terre dans le panier donc enfin un petit
couteau et une lune et contre la base à
condition cependant de ne pas les
confondre
regardez les fip et ben non c'était une
feuille je me suis fait typiquement je
me suis fait avoir presque deux heures
de balade en forêt de marly pour amener
des paniers bien remplie dernier coup
d'oeil de l'expert avant de partir los
angeles et bien vérifier ces champignons
avant de les transformer en omelette ou
en fricassée un réflexe à ne pas manquer
les autorités sanitaires appellent à la
vigilance suite à de nombreux cas
d'intoxication ces dernières semaines